yeah and the dungeon here what's
happening nick the tournament right baby
great to be here my man lisa and now
brother it was good i saw that movie
dope which is actually really good all
right uh we went to the comedy store oh
right thank you steve simone and uh just
kind of hung around no more orange is
the new black i we finished that so it
was a good weekend how's utah tremendous
wise guys a great club
i went to schuler's restaurant
schuler has a restaurant in the embassy
yeah he's got a chain of them
not big house right yeah steakhouse not
bad
not bad i think michael jordan's
steakhouse is better but i haven't been
to that in fact he's got one too i had a
mohican son
not bad yeah not bad the seafood towel i
don't have the money somebody else took
us i don't know we were performing there
and some guy goes go there you got
a meal confidence i had some cuban food
yesterday down in uh malibu how was it
it's good what place cafe habana and
malibu yeah i thought it was more like
almost mexican but it was it was a
little skirt
skirt steak black beans and rice yeah
black beans
bananas fried bananas all right
beautiful what was it it was good
nothing like queens no
unlike those not like miami dirty
kitchens where you send me all porter
saguaro yeah that's the [ __ ] best i
know if i had to go between hands down
for the best cuban food i've had old
school because i come from a different
school of it it's border saga and this
little [ __ ] hole in the wall in
edgewater new jersey
which was [ __ ] just sensational i
mean they had everything traditional
which i liked what was that soup you
told me to have
the cuban chicken soup
is that the one with the fidel and the
[ __ ] potatoes yeah lee's gonna flip
these
have you taken them now no what's in it
just chicken soup it's a little it's a
a more chickeny broth and like matzo
ball soup okay and it's got no little
noodles potatoes better than that blood
soup the filipinos eat yeah yeah
freaking they they made my in-laws make
these freaking uh they butcher the
animals in the backyard the goat
had this [ __ ] blood soup one time in
south carolina last year i said i ain't
eating that [ __ ] the aroma yeah like
like death like freaking death i said
i'm not eating that i eat the roast pig
you know they're bringing the rose it's
great there's a liver dip that they
bring in with the roast pig and it
sounds nasty but the dip is unbelievable
then you take the skin the father chops
up the pig you know
and the skin is so good you taste the
skin you dip the skin in the liver dip
my own is great i'm telling you man do
they really do they do like the whole
pig back there they bring the whole pig
no somebody cooks it then they bring it
in right and you look at the whole pig
and then he takes a big hatchet you
gotta know how to cut this sucker up
jesus they're pros at it these filipinos
know you know that's what they do they
butcher [ __ ] what is filipino food i
like i almost went to one the other week
but i don't know what it is it's like
it's like a cross between
asian and
little spanish but more primitive
animals
goats yeah [ __ ] pigeons don't [ __ ]
eat anything there's a lot of guineas
[ __ ] italians that you know they
cook pigeons and goats and lamb
and take him right in the bathroom this
old time guy was telling me his father
used to bring the animals or goats or
whatever
chop him up in the freaking bathroom
because this is the dinner tonight he
tell the guys
he used to drown these pigeons his dad
dad's that drowned the pigeons
i don't know he was telling me why he
drowned i forgot this it was a funny
story he's he's got to tell the story
because when he told me how he drowned
the pigeons and [ __ ]
i would die laughing
and i used to catch his blue crabs in
jersey my friend used to make the blue
crabs go to sleep he rubbed their
stomach and [ __ ] in the sink
and the blue cribs would go to sleep
yeah you know how to handle them i catch
them in the backyard you know just put
the how good are the blue crabs with the
red sauce they're great
they sit there and eat those freaking
crabs they got they know how to eat that
[ __ ] it's so tedious
you know i clean them good because those
filipinos they leave a lot of the crap
in there i get sick on that [ __ ] i had
the runs one time i'm like i'm running
for my life i had [ __ ] coming down my
leg and everything
i was like i make sure i clean those
crabs good what's the craziest thing the
in-laws have cooked
that you looked at and doubted what the
[ __ ] am i doing here no the blood soup
that was that was one of the craziest
things but yeah is it red is it red i
don't just the uh the smell was i just
couldn't get past the smell
what would you do if someone brought you
blood soup juice would die i can't eat
that [ __ ] you know i don't get myself in
those positions no i'm a picky [ __ ]
either yeah like once i get invited to
those uh parties i always try to bow
down because they're so warm and they'll
ask you to eat yeah and you're like huh
like my cousin lives with us for years
this kid gabe is like forrest gump he's
hilarious one of the funniest guys in
america he eats chicken he eats the
cartilage he eats the whole [ __ ] he even
eats his i don't know what the college
is but he crunches he chews on like what
are you eating it's the cottage it's the
college and he eats everything the whole
[ __ ] chicken i mean the guy is loves
chicken he was probably a chicken in his
best life this guy eats everything
that's the whole [ __ ] thing
everything in jail the black dudes eat
the chicken till the [ __ ] thing they
don't even let it get reincarnated
then black [ __ ] in prison
you'll see him for an hour twisting that
bone like that's it enough yeah what are
you getting out of that [ __ ] thing
that chicken i can't even make a
comeback he's gonna make a comeback with
one wing and one off yeah i thought of
you yesterday there's this guy on vine
and he took a video of himself at like
the parking lot of a prison and he could
hear him yelling at the black guys and
the black guy's yelling back like the
one guy said like you're in a gay girl
car like you have a square like square
head [ __ ] like they're just
yelling at each other from the cells to
like the parking lot i just thought of
you and that story you always tell but
like how just loud they are
i can never eat a chicken to the end
like that
i know there's a lot of the chicken i
don't trust not a part of the chicken i
don't trust when i get a costco chicken
i eat the white meat i ate a little bit
of the skin and that's it yeah if the
wing looks ratty i'll leave that thing
alone like it's got two or three strings
on it
now i only like thighs two thighs and
and and legs and i don't like the
freaking breasts it's too dry and [ __ ] i
won't go to another fast food joints for
chicken i stopped that a long time ago
even though i break down once in one go
to popeyes no popeye's like a
[ __ ] they got a wing and a thigh
for 1.49 give me the [ __ ] runs
popeyes does it really yeah it's greasy
[ __ ] uh one time and uh you're better
off going into ralph's and just say can
i have 25 pieces let them make it fresh
you got to get it french fresh yeah yeah
you know you know who got that for their
wedding
you're looking at them you my wife knew
the people and every time she went the
lady would give her the fresh chicken
[ __ ] delicious rob's got a thing now
if you got a piece of fish
they'll fry the fish up for you very
nice too you ever go to diners chicken
that's pretty good too by the airport
it's an old-school chicken place diners
by the lax yeah it's good you're going
there you get a whole barrel of chicken
i mean it's like old school fried
chicken i like good fried chicken i like
good fried chicken i do man when you
i'll go i'll go to places you know if i
find good fried chicken when i came from
cuba i used to tear up the colonel yeah
but not in front of my mother my mother
wouldn't let me have uh
fast food growing up in new york city so
and you can make chicken a lot of
different ways man you know
what
wade boggs was a baseball player he ate
chicken in his whole career for every
game
i did a commercial with him i asked him
did you really eat [ __ ] chicken did
you eat chicken noodle and he was like
yeah i ate chicken my whole career i
gotta eat chicken cutlets every day yeah
they've got to be mashed potatoes
with creamed corn yeah and cranberries
juice and some club soda and that
[ __ ] yeah
god damn get me hungry you always take
cream corn i don't know
corn is good i could eat chicken cutlets
everything you notice cuban joint made
uh they put some like cheese on the corn
on the cob i don't know if it's a cuban
thing it was very good it was like a
grated cheese
yeah mexicans have that too it must have
been like a mexican style don't [ __ ]
with my corn i like hotel bob butter on
my corn
a little salt and heavy on the pepper
pepper that [ __ ] corn is brand new
now it's good corn jersey jersey corn oh
the sweet [ __ ] but let me explain
something
the reason why you don't like cream corn
is because the people made it for you
just give it to you out of the can any
professional knows you got to dope that
[ __ ] up
okay you dope it up and now you go to
vegas or now my wife makes the cream
corn with little pieces of jalapeno on
that [ __ ] to give it some flavor
and some extra butter and some extra
salt and pepper but is it better than
just corn on the cob
is amazing it's amazing but it calls
different dishes call for different
things i see what you're saying i'm
pounding chicken cutlets i don't have
time to [ __ ] put butter
when i consider a corn on the cob i'm
eating it with a baked potato and a nice
[ __ ] steak yeah
okay so everything has a different
[ __ ] patois i feel you how about
cream spinach like creamed spinach if
it's made correctly and you know what i
like it with if i tell you what i like
crispy spinach this is i'm a kid spam
spam is good fried spam yeah fried
spring spinach fresh creamed spinach
fried spice garlic in that [ __ ]
stop it i love cream spinach spam is not
good yes it is
if you show up like a gentile and just
cut it and [ __ ] no no you gotta put some
salt and pepper today i made a burger
but i had my wife taste the burger and
she goes jesus christ i go i've been
asking you put the chopped meat together
no i get these burger patties
85 percent nice i take them home yeah i
roll a little garlic salt on them i put
a little [ __ ] onion salt on that
[ __ ] you grill it hella heavy on
the pepper right i take it outside and i
grill it and i put little holes in it so
it cooks the inside and right before
that last piece i take a little butter
hey you want to go to a good butcher
down at the grove in the middle of the
grill i'm not doing that no i swear it's
not going to happen there's a guy there
it's not even worse they got a [ __ ]
cowboy steak in there you'll go out of
your mind
no it's in it's in it's in the farmer's
market listen the guy goes to a ranch he
gets this cowboy steak right so do i i
don't think joey would go to the grocery
wouldn't you go to the [ __ ] grove if
you paid me though yeah but go there for
the butcher i won't go there he's got
these sweet sausages listen to me the
only way i would go down there if
somebody's giving a hundred dollar bills
really that's it i wouldn't even
test it
i don't see why i got driving that
traffic anymore 52 years of age i i got
one foot in the grave one of banana pee
i'm going to waste 20 minutes go get
sausages it's going to be menza morta
i'm going to new york instead of time
and i'm saying i hear you man i'm done
i'm done with the [ __ ] driving lee
knows everybody i get myself i'm done
i'm done i did the listen well done
uh we were talking before last week i
[ __ ] up and i had two slices of pizza
lee knows
i'm to the point in my life now where i
only eat pizza from one place that mall
over here got joe's new yorker
yeah ain't bad jokes i go over there
that's it give it up on everything where
is it when you walk in i've never seen
downstairs in the food court all the way
in the back they got them in the dungeon
next to the japanese people that they
closed down
but that [ __ ] moore got some food now
they got a cheesesteak place they got
the chinese place they got a [ __ ] a
sandwich place at the end which mall are
you talking about this one right here
not even not even the galleria you're
talking about the one on riverside and
woodland woodman yeah
tremendous pizza yeah yeah that's where
they have the jokes it's pretty good
pretty [ __ ] good
dad i went overboard i had the sausage
and the pepperoni because i'm a cheese
slice [ __ ] you know me though
just give me the cheese whoa why [ __ ]
around yeah anything i did you put that
chicken teriyaki slice next to my slice
gouge your [ __ ] eyeball out you
understand me don't give me no chicken
you don't try fusion pizza no why would
i do something like that you don't want
to put chicken i don't do nothing like
that i don't disrespect have you tried
blaze
the blaze pizzeria they make the pizzas
really fish you could build your own pie
no it ain't bad for it it's more like
the chipotle
of pizza but it ain't bad them chipotle
oh yeah i'll stick with joe's hey here
you are i break down every six weeks
with a slice of pizza i was explaining
to you there is a joint but if you want
to treat yourself in in pasadena called
it's the bellow and it's almost like a
brick oven slice it's not bad if you
want to treat yourself no we gotta we go
to we go to the ice house once a month
so we'll so go over there
set
like a brick oven slice it's like you
know it said that stuff is from italy
they get all this [ __ ] from italy it's
the real deal how's the cheese great i'm
telling you it's great i know good pizza
it's it's a good slice of pizza is the
square kind called neapolitan or what is
it
like we were growing up once we were
raised i like sicilian i love sicilian
but there's an art to that not everybody
can make a good slice of sicilian
if not it's just bread with [ __ ]
sauce on it right yeah some people like
nick the greek yeah the greek he made a
nicer silly put it by the window the
flies landed on it they used it as a
take off
every time you got a slice of a ceiling
you gotta look for a fly in that
[ __ ] you know when you make a
good square too there was a place in my
neighbor called jns they made this
square pizza and my dad used to go
insane if i could just get the freaking
recipe i'm like that we're never going
to get the recipe or something it's been
there still there j s but nobody makes
it like them you know when somebody
makes something unique you just go wow
that's a great [ __ ] slice of pizza
you know just like patsy's the original
patches you go to harlem it's great
they're still there the oven is a
thousand years old still there still
there man you can go in and get a pie
for 10 bucks
that oven is so old that's why it's so
good the oven it's the oven man it's
unbelievable i love that go to a yankee
game stop and haul them let's go to
passes let's get a pie
and then go to the game he's on the way
yeah he did on the way man i i did that
one time with sandler and all the guys i
don't know as long as short or chuck and
i i was eating some freaking they go
where do you get where'd you get that i
go
call them now i said they ordered all
these pies they were like holy [ __ ] this
is good
yeah i know how to eat you guys don't
know how to eat they don't know what to
eat and i mean i had to freaking turn
them on that's what i do man i eat i
know good food i know a good burger i
know a good slice of pizza a good
sandwich sounds like a good looking
mortadella a little [ __ ] suprasad and
fresh buffalo mozzarella
put a little olive oil oh it's [ __ ]
great nice prosciutto mortadella with
some whipped cream
and a [ __ ] nice bread a little olive
oil maybe a roasted red pepper like a
[ __ ] yes some maybe some mom
it's unbelievable oh all right have you
ever had that no i haven't had [ __ ]
you'd go [ __ ] nuts
i'm going to get your sandwich like that
i'm done oh my god with those stuffed
peppers with the mozzarella and they're
a little sad and i'm telling you a
little more the dow a little super side
and a little prosciutto oh my god have
you been to domingos in encino it's good
yeah that mingles makes a good sandwich
it's a good place until the guy was here
the last time i was there i had a bad
experience
i was having a great time
i was waiting for my sandwich and
awesome johnny gentile walked in there
the whitest guy in america was slippers
on and was pissed about his turkey
why would you go in there for turkey in
the first i wanted to smack him
and i kept saying why don't you go to
subway what a subway photography
jersey every [ __ ] turkey in the world
right why are you wasting your time in
italian [ __ ] place in encino looking
for [ __ ] plain turkey yeah that was
mad i don't want smoked turkey get the
[ __ ] out of it go eat dick right you
don't like smoked turkey why is that
domingo's fault though because that
that's what i'm saying why is it
domingo's fault why is this guy in there
if i was domingo i wouldn't allow this
guy in there with his [ __ ] slippers
looking for a turkey he said we don't
make turkey sandwiches all right go down
the [ __ ] corner i tried to get the
euro last time we were in boston this
place uh umberto is in the north end
it's like what it's what you like they
have like a whole bunch of like ready
pies and they just stick in the oven and
like they're the big ones so each slice
is really two slices [ __ ] amazing you
know what's great a [ __ ] great
meatball
when you get a meatball that's just my
mom used to make it with veal
and lamb
and beef and it would just fall apart it
was magical what a feeling when it was
in the sauce just floating in just
not too big not too bready oh my god
holy [ __ ] it's like a piece of bread
it's like sucking something that's like
you know you're sucking something that's
like gold
i mean you know how long you've been
anita
forever yeah when did you just well how
old were you when you discovered the
greatest thing in the world what was
that as i've gotten older as i've gotten
older i think when i was a kid i was
finicky and i i didn't have great eating
hat i didn't appreciate the food until i
was an adult until i started making my
own sauce then i named myself nikki red
sauce
you know because i made a great sauce
everybody was like hey nikki red sauce i
was like yeah i actually had it in the
[ __ ] jar but it didn't last long
because i didn't have any backing but it
came out really good did you go to shark
tank no no no sure we had a real [ __ ]
sauce
i was in 50 stores man
you yeah it was like a rail sauce it was
a high-end sauce we made it with the
pork bone everything in new haven
connecticut i'll show you the jar
you showed it to me yeah you remember i
told you about it you didn't go to shark
tank no no sure
we got charlie bronson up there yeah
that's great
you got to have bronson whatever you
want what a [ __ ] unbelief just look
at that face
i mean you know he didn't even have to
act with a face like that you just show
up
you know when you look at those faces
years ago like i look at these guys i
wish i wish i had a face like i mean my
face i have a good face but those guys
had those guys had [ __ ] incredible
faith like these movie stars today they
had no they have no character there's no
robert mitchum there's no [ __ ]
you know charles bronson there's no
there's no excuse my boyfriend there's
no paul newman
this is all [ __ ] and charles look at
that face wow look at that stash show
the people at home the pictures
victor mature
oh my god my dad resembles victor mature
stud man
stud
look at charles like right there in that
movie i can't tell what scene that it
could be what is that mechanic is that
it really looks to me like the mechanic
it really does michael vincent
[ __ ] jam michael remember him listen
bro
uh
good job michael vincent
i think richard gere
every year he gives to the jan michael
vincent foundation does he sure because
if jan michael vincent wouldn't have
stopped drinking wouldn't have started
drinking
chad michael vincent would have still
been [ __ ] people up
you'd watch the not the blue lagoon
watch the one he did for disney
the one before the mechanic he did
disney the world's strongest man right
when he picks his arms up and [ __ ] that
was a [ __ ] he was the original brad
pitt brad pitt would have to suck his
dick yeah brad pitt in in the mechanic
jan michael vincent
was throwing a [ __ ] heat that nobody
had thrown since like you know early
robert redford or something that was
like a [ __ ] beautiful man yeah and he
started [ __ ] booze and that was did
you ever see the movie defiance
he made a movie defiance about a long
shoreman
no i never saw it manhattan him paulie
walnuts danny aiello that's how long ago
really this is 70
if the mechanic was 73 this was 75. is
it good
the guy that played the gang leader was
badass yeah throw it on lee see if
defiance is on there like the trailer
i was watching deliverance in the
deliverance like that was a good flavor
that's a good fight man good actor burt
reynolds was tremendous that was great
defiance and michael vincent see if they
got anything
and throw that up that's an old school
movie
and all those guys were in acting class
that's how they probably got that movie
yeah diallo
paulie walnuts
and there's somebody else young as [ __ ]
defiance must have been an early uh
i'm gonna slip by sometimes you know
19 1980s there's they're saying
i'm gonna get them you know here's
another name i'm gonna throw at you
whatever happened to uh
ken wall
he was [ __ ] good remember
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah oh my god though
good looking
the wanderers but he was also in that
show on cbs nice guy
my parents why he was handsome he could
act i'm the kind of guy one of my
favorite movies i love that i wish i was
in there
oh my god i told sam about that i was
like you should have been leave the kid
alone
look at him oh [ __ ] that's him look at
him
that dude would have busted the bank now
guys
see if there's something else there how
do i get this on netflix i don't know
this is on youtube let me see if there's
another one
yeah dog this is he was still hot in
this one
what happened to him drugs alcohol they
did uh behind the hollywood whatever
about him and it was really interesting
because
he was [ __ ]
drunk i mean he has no teeth now yeah
well this is when they show them yeah
they're basically just the life
i'm not sure
wow
either when i can get here yeah hey
you take care of yourself man yeah yeah
you keep liking me
this guy ladies and gentlemen if you've
ever seen jam michael vincent
he was about to burn the [ __ ] bank
but right there this was there i don't
know what he could have he did sky wolf
a show for cbs he recurred
there's a raw deal you got tummy
what the hell am i going to do
i think she got a godfather
you tell them i got this
i'm on suspension
oh [ __ ]
well you can't sleep on a goddamn docks
i got a brother-in-law it's got an
apartment building in the city get
yourself a place there
it ain't gracie mansion but it's cheap
what the hell am i gonna do in this city
i hate this place i can't even breathe
here
i ain't got any money anyway
yeah i have some more orange
this is
oh my god i saw him in the james brown
movie gained a lot of weight craig
robinson oh yeah that was a good movie
though the james brown movie yeah i
watched it today
bits and pieces i mean i like that kid
but i i don't know if he's dark enough
to play james brown i mean i don't mean
don't taste my kid is [ __ ] good he's
talented everything that kid does he's
good he's good and drafted he's good in
42. he's good in 40 yeah
he works hard
works on everything they're putting him
on everything now he's going to be on a
roll now he's going to win an oscar
but you know i was thinking about nick
the other day everybody today man on
fire was on and the godfather at three
o'clock that's your double header a debt
that's your move man on fire oh please
and i had to work i had to do a bunch of
[ __ ] but i caught the last
10 minutes which is the movie once he
starts blasting a little mexicans well
my favorite is training day i love it
really that's a good that's a good idea
i love him in that see i like him in
that i love him i don't know why man the
more that's like one of those movies
that the more i've watched it the more i
liked it it was like the town the more i
watched it oh my gosh
i love that was the best thing he ever
did that was just evil enough he's like
he's evil in that movie it gets like oh
he's right uh denzel he gets
progressively more evil and like he's so
uh like
charismatic i guess yeah that you almost
like him he's such a low life that you
know he's [ __ ] the girl up until like
the last scene you still kind of like
him a little bit man when he shoots his
friend
breathe dog breathe
i'm like what the [ __ ] i gotta tax you a
little bit
gotta shoot him shoot him he's telling
the guy shoot him that scene is
unbelievable
bam he's like you know at the scene when
he goes to the house with all the guys
yeah and he's got to tax the guy and all
this [ __ ] and he gives the mic money to
behringer tom barrett yeah barringer
yeah and the guy they gotta get the okay
and [ __ ] you know those are oldest yeah
those are good actors those guys from
scratch
who had gum on his shoe when he shot him
the lieutenant the one who shook him
down at the bar right that's a great
scene when he's that's euless heron
whatever the guy that was like you know
how this works tony you know that guy
how this works charlie
i was gonna bring denzel up don't go too
far tony don't do it too far don't go
too far you can't shoot a cop remember
that guy oh my goodness
oh my god yes [ __ ] pacino oh it was
great
fly fly
but i gotta tell you something i love
denzel but
i'll tell you who's really a bad
[ __ ] nobody gives them enough
credit
and i'm gonna say why
pink floyd has a song called pigs
three drifting ones
i i i know people are going to get upset
with this but i know you're going to
understand where i'm coming from the
song no someday they're going to make a
song called
let's tell the story first the guy's
name is lawrence fishburn
i think lawrence fishburne is the best
black actor
pound for pound he squeaks it at the
note you know what the track
he just beats it and i'll tell you why
because he plays three different types
of moulin yawns
okay and i can't and he but it's the
same mulligan listen in okay in the one
with walking
he remember when he goes to new york oh
oh yeah okay but then he comes back like
i turn i turn oh that's bad oh and
that's a complete different type of
brother do you understand what i'm
trying to say he's great in boys in the
hood too and oh my god that's the father
[ __ ] greatest guys he's the most he's
not as he's not as good looking as
denzel he's not as charismatic as that
but i i agree with you he's right up
there oh my god well he's got one other
one he plays a different type of play
right up there he's right up there i
think his problem might be that a lot of
people my age don't know him other than
the matrix he's been alive and
if you ask like someone under under 30
they'll probably send it isn't that yeah
but when you when i was under 30 and i
saw denzel and gloria i knew there was
no turning back and then i saw him in
the movie with you
mm-hmm the trumpet better i i knew that
was my first movie i was at that i knew
there was no table reading i said to my
brother i was nervous my first move was
so excited to be in the freaking room
there was all these great people robin
harris oh my god he took over the room
and he destroyed everybody including
denzel
my brother said this guy is a [ __ ]
he's going to become huge and then he'd
fall asleep right at the reading
and then when denzel was reading and
[ __ ] i said to my brother wow who is
this guy he goes oh he's [ __ ] he's
gonna be a big big star he's this is
denzel washington we did a scene with
him i remember i was i wasn't there was
my first movie so i was i wasn't him i
was out of my light or some [ __ ] he goes
nick just move over here and move over
there i was like oh okay see my brother
goes yeah he's looking out for you nick
see he's looking out for you but i knew
i said i was working with like a star i
mean his focus his look everything i
mean i was just you know concentrate on
what i had to do but i was like wow i'm
in the scene with this [ __ ] this
is this is this guy's hot man he's
bringing it when guy you know guys show
up like that and you're there bringing
it it excites the [ __ ] feels like when i
worked with red dog you know years ago
on blue first year and we became friends
me and caruso and i was like i knew i
said this guy is
coming with it you know because it gets
you excited that's what people don't
understand when other people are good
you know it just but you know he's a
star man he's a star and he's and i
heard he's a little bit of a he can be a
diva too i've heard he's done that right
he ain't boom nothing i'm talking about
oh
so he got him twice yeah he just he just
how many seasons have happened
yeah he got rich taking his sunglasses
off and doing i'm not talking about that
yeah that guy was in the [ __ ] water
yeah somebody was looking out for him
somebody up above was looking out for
that guy in the [ __ ] water we're
friends and somebody was looking out for
him well when i tell you you know
because the guys that acted that that
way and through you know threw that away
they never get another shot never
so he was lucky that somebody came
looking for him but you know that
doesn't always mean you have that you're
very happy because you know he wanted to
make it in the movies that was the thing
for him you know he used to always say
you know nick we gotta we gotta make it
on the big screen this is this is you
know this is the little screen you know
to him that was his that was his dream
that's why he like sabotaged himself you
know because he wanted to like it wasn't
big enough for him you know he should
have played his cards right and maybe he
would have had a little bit that's
amazing
and he's in it early on yeah he was good
character actor early on but he didn't
jump off later on like when they gave
him these starring roles like i think he
was just one of those guys that was
better on the little screen he was good
in jade
yeah he was put in jail it wasn't a good
movie that's the only problem it was a
shitty movie the other one was a
weak movie
kiss it oh that was a kiss yeah that was
weak that was fun that's the one that
was funny you know who's like watching
that for cage right cage is funnier than
that who else yeah he's funny he's
actually funny in that hunt
huh hunters in that movie lauren hunt
right what's the name from the chick
from oh yeah lower ten names what's her
name
helen hunt helen hunter helen hudson
helen hunt yeah it wasn't a ravaport
they tied them up and my friend rapper
bought yeah nicholas cage played the
strip club owner with the asthma yeah
yeah i think they offered that part to
my brother i think he turned that he
turns down a lot of stuff
because caruso was saying yeah i gotta
get your brother tell him to do it tell
him to do it i was like i can't tell him
to do it yeah johnny's like you can't
tell john to do anything john's a
different animal you can't tell him but
uh i worked with cage i worked with him
in the oliver stone the world trade
center movie he was a nice guy a nice
guy you know
oliver stone was a bastard he was a bad
he destroyed everybody and one time nick
cage goes don't worry about it he calls
me jethro from the beverly hillbillies
and so really nick i said man this guy's
[ __ ] nuts oliver stone this guy sucks
that guy sucks he sucks everybody sucks
i said you [ __ ] i fought back one
time cause oh you're getting mad now
you're getting mad i like that i like
that i was like yeah because you destroy
everybody's confidence if you don't do
anything he'd tell you ah you got
nothing then if you try to do something
you say you're so over the top did
oliver stone through the football one
yeah he's always he almost got into a
fist fight with dean kane at the [ __ ]
audition oh he did he they stood up they
had to break the camera yeah had to get
in the middle he's a bully
what do you call i think had a punch out
with him years ago woods or somebody
james woods i think
an old movie salvador he had a punch out
with him he went over to my wife one day
he likes asian women he was rubbing her
hair i said hey he goes oh
how did you get her
never mind how i get high i said well
you want me to get you an asian girl
i'll get you an asian girl because it
was this girl like i knew one day goes
can i can i meet her can i meet her i
said yeah you could meet her she was
with this fat gangster guy that i know i
said come over here
oliver stone made her like a star she
was an extra he brought in a [ __ ]
trailer for an extra
i swear to god i swear to god this guy
was nuts
he's [ __ ] nuts i don't want to work
with that guy he was like hey you want
to be like jackie gleason you want to
ham it up you're looking in the camera
i'm not looking in the camera i go
you're smoking too much pot
i'm looking in the camera you guys nuts
i went back for the the call back he was
calling me timmy or something
he goes i want you in the movie i go you
want me in a movie you call me a
different name
he goes no but i love the way you talk
listen listen to his accent he goes he's
got a better accent than de niro
i said yeah but get my [ __ ] name
right
he's calling me timmy or robert i don't
know what the i said no you called me
because i know but this is what i have
left
there was a lot of guys in the movie we
had a lot of fun that was right after my
mom passed that was
thinking about when bill buffer was here
they kept calling bruce buffer bruce
buffalo
jimmy oh it's like when i had a
haircutting job when i was not at the
hey i was a i was washing jewish women's
heads when i was a kid and the owner uh
this is a funny story why were you doing
this because it was a summer job and
they said do you want to wash hair i
said i'll try it and i didn't like it
all these jewish women were yelling at
me harder how much are they painting
harder not much i had to sweep the
[ __ ] hair and rub these and and i
couldn't like i couldn't even shampoo
the hair hard enough they would be like
they were very picky jewish long island
i was a kid young kid but the owner his
name was nick he goes what's your name i
go nick because you can't be nick i'm
nick
he goes what are you what am i gonna
call you i said i don't know call me
richie he goes all right richie so this
was funny i worked there for like one
day two days he go richie
richie richie i wouldn't answer oh
that's me that's me all day long richie
richie richie and i was like oh yeah
yeah i'm like [ __ ] this i can't i can't
work here i can't be [ __ ] richie my
mother almost named me richard thank god
my brother she was gonna name you richie
yeah cause you know they call you dick i
don't want to be richard thank god i
wasn't [ __ ] richie excuse me put that
air on please i'm dying yeah i'm dying
over here yeah you gotta put the [ __ ]
heat on i tell them every day
he has me and then it's [ __ ] it's a
good story right [ __ ]
one day
richie richie my brother tries to rob my
material
that's funny tell me that again no no i
don't want to tell you
it'll wind up in your [ __ ] script
i didn't like that job i had a lot of
when i was a kid i'd have a job for one
day and i would quit after one day oh my
god i was bus boy lenny's clan bar
treated like dog meat
one time to yours
ups oh my god it made you work like a
[ __ ] animal four hours for eight
dollars and that was blood blood money
oh ups yeah and you had it you had to
push out about you had a ton of 2 000
packages in an hour in an hour you got
to touch them
my father said
[ __ ] quit that [ __ ] job he thought
that's that's your uncle mikey they gave
him a truck and he gave him the truck
back
he said don't ever work for those
[ __ ] people ups what was this what
you were i thought this was like in the
80s or something i applied for you oh my
god 1980 and my buddy got the job if i
show you have a camera i'm gonna i sho
i'll show you how i had to work i mean
physically i could show you no i know
how to work because he used to thomas
and he's still there listen to this i
went with that kid winter of 81 they
were hiring for the christmas holidays
yes
both applied right they kept him do you
know until this day
wow he's still there i made a career out
of it seven years ago they gave him one
point something three point something
yeah because his stock options and his
vacation they went public yeah went
public wow so
i talked to his brother me that's the
kid i robbed the jewelry store with he
became a [ __ ] born-again christian
now he won't talk to me but the brother
of me is still tight and the brother
tells me that they're trying to get rid
of him now because now they're paying
him six figures
and he you know he wasn't even supposed
to be there at this point
look look at nicki dope and oh you got
the shirt you got the shirt yeah nah
that's not for the movie this is dope
but um yeah oh my god i had
the only job i kept when i was 15 i kept
a job working as a hard carrier for an
italian guy i really like mr severino i
really enjoyed his i learned a lot from
him i think how he ate today
from
seven to five he'd have five small
tremendous meals right but half of what
you would get at home you know mm-hmm
that's the way to eat a piece of lasagna
little piece lasagna an apple he'd have
a little wine glass she put saran wrap
on it from he had wine at 11 o'clock
with fruit
he ate cheese at one he ate a really
weird diet and i went back 10 years ago
and there's mr severino looking the way
he looked [ __ ] 40 years ago when i
was a kid wow so it worked you know he
worked that little island diet he was
from uh sicily and he worked at ireland
they know how to eat those
i didn't quit that i didn't quit my
mom's bar i liked that i i the other day
i wanted to oh when i went to schuler's
i went in saturday afternoon to get
lunch and the girl was there by herself
to bargain and she goes thank god you
came in i know how long you have this
job she goes three weeks it's brutal she
goes i forgot i didn't take the summer
into consideration that people don't go
to bars in the summer in the daytime you
know right and i go this was my first
job
me the [ __ ] i took a job on saturday
days
like the first week of july at this bar
i made four dollars the first saturday i
went in the second saturday cleaned up a
little bit i got to get the [ __ ] out of
here oh job i [ __ ] hated kfc i had
that for like a day maybe a day or two
did you do i don't remember i was in the
back with the chicken or some [ __ ] it
was bad it was a bad [ __ ] job i was
like this sucks i never worked at a fast
food yeah i did mcdonald's a couple of
months but my mom said are you eating
the food too much quit that job then i
wound up as a produce kid at king cullen
that i liked except i got six i used to
go from the cold to the hot i was
wrapping fruit and
then i started getting sick from going
out to the cold
but i liked it in the back you know i
met some girl with curly hair name was
lisa ferrara i remember that one with
the big knockers
you sucker tits in the freezer no i
never thought that titties i want her
crazy boyfriend attacked me from the
weeds i remember that girl because she
was hot oh my god
yeah let me just remember those stories
but no i never held on to a lot of jobs
except when i worked for a hotel and
that was one job that i liked and then
i was a bellman for a summer i said oh
[ __ ] this is
this is not bad i said this in manhattan
yeah it was a summer job my father was
there in construction john was there in
construction and my mom said
why don't you get him a job as a bellhop
it's a new hotel i just thought i was
going to college at home and
and first night i don't know what i made
like 100 110 i had like a jewish
bankroll looked like i had a thousand
dollars my dad opened the door and he
said
how much you make kid i said it's right
there dad like a hundred and ten is what
uh yo you kidding me when crazy yeah
cash man
[ __ ] cash he's loaded my father was
like and i was sucking it away my father
was like look at him in that cheap skit
look at that skin friend he used to call
me you see he's saving every [ __ ]
nickel look at him i was like you got me
the job so i was making money man i
loved it i was making all kinds of money
and then it was a fun job you worked
five days a week i was working on a
summer job five days a week the fun was
like at night once in a while i got my
friend a job
my friend in gracia he was the night man
so once in a while i would fill in for
him at night but at night there was no
business so and gracie even told me if
you ever work for me tutorial at night
you got to be like room service you got
to be almost like a you got to be a
different type of bellman at night so
like if you go on the menu and you see
that there's a bottle of champagne for
65 dollars you know you could go buy it
for eight you know 10 15
replace it with the bar and then charge
the guys 65 dollars like one time count
basically wanted a hamburger i went to
burger king count basie and that burger
was like 10 bucks i took a burger king
burger and put it like just in a regular
freaking aluminum foil and he was like
how much i go you know ten dollars mr
basie he was like wow why so much i said
well i'm room service everything's
closed man two o'clock in the morning
you know at one time these freaking
iranians and these middle easterners
wanted women i never did that before i
went out like my plymouth valiant i
found a couple of chicks on the street i
snuck them in and brought them up to the
room i felt like a pimp you know and
these uh iranians or whatever they were
they were like not suitable not suitable
i said well [ __ ] you man not suitable i
went on the street to get these broads
and they were pissed they were like
what's wrong with these smelly ugly
bastards i said oh no i know shower no i
mean the men are dirty not the women or
the
and that later on became a doorman at a
different hotel saint maritz but this
was on the east side it was a helmsley
hotel
holly hotel i liked it the white gloves
black shoes i remember telling my friend
he got the job
yeah i said come with black shoes are
going to send your ass home it comes in
with [ __ ] brown shoes and they sent
them home i thought i [ __ ] told you
to come in with black shoes man not
brown but it was a good job but in a way
it was a trap because you know i saw
that you could make easy money and [ __ ]
like that and you know i don't want to
get stuck and then when i was looking to
make money again i got back into that
hotel business because i knew you could
make money in it you know but it was and
my brother was like i don't want to see
you get stuck in that [ __ ] nick that's a
trap you know
one of the first jobs i had was a place
called jay har and sons
they hired high school kids
from two to
nine or ten or eleven whatever you could
do it's just a warehouse loading trucks
and i worked with this funny black guy
the guy cracked me up all day you know
he was a man you know
but we went out for him and got bottles
of uh blackberry brandy and you know he
knew the guy at the liquor store we
smoked weed with them
and when he had a big afro one night
you had to have one of those things
that you they put the boxes on and you
pick up and
a hand truck a hand truck yeah we had
hand trucks and you would he would stock
the hand trucks and you'd pull them away
and stock them you had some crews
stocking the trucks
i forget what this guy's name was
and
there was a goofy white dude and he was
stalking the things and the black guy
went to bend over and he let the thing
go and i remember that the
the hand truck
got him in the head like this
oh [ __ ] but he didn't get hurt he didn't
believe nothing but the funny thing was
when they took him out
the metal from the thing went into his
afro he had like a four-inch afro he
walked around like that and we couldn't
stop [ __ ] laughing for hours that's
my adventure in the warehouse business
i was there for two days and my mother
came in there
like the second day and she goes i just
got a call from the high school you were
supposed to go to the doctor what do you
mean you're spitting blood
i was spitting blood i had a lung
infection in high school i got a lung
infection and i went to play football
and i started spitting pure blood every
time my heart beat i would spit pure
blood
and uh scary they called my big i was
supposed to come back to school the
doctors know i never did i thought they
would forget about it [ __ ] no
what was it
the in the 70s they were spraying
marijuana with paraquad a chemical to to
destroy the
the [ __ ] whatever it's called the
plant
but some people still picked it and some
people smoked i was one of those jerk
offs that i got sold to right and i got
a lung infection i ended up in the
hospital for 13 days oh man how old were
you
15 16 right there in the middle in those
13 days whatever those 11 days in the
hospital
i got out the night i lead lost to
holmes maybe
79
september of 79 i got up
and ali was fighting that's why they
threw me out they're like we can't take
another night because my friends are
coming to visit me they were throwing
furniture out the hotel window they were
showing up with cases of beers
broads it was [ __ ] crazy you know
at 15.
at 15. all these guys were crazy when i
got sick a lot of people
you know i had good friends at the time
like high school buddies and they were
showing up and smoking pot in the hole
in the hospital room and blowing it out
the window and oh my god it was 11 i
tormented them from the first night i
got in there in the hospital why because
the first night i got in i had never
been to hospital before i didn't know
what to expect i'm [ __ ] uh
white coat fear you know what i'm saying
like i have fear and at that time i
didn't know about breathing i knew
nothing all i knew was about fainting
and i went went to sleep finally i
didn't even really sleep good and that
night i peed the bed
but they had rubber sheets so the whole
everything was wet i got a [ __ ]
drenched oh my gosh and in the middle of
sitting there i never forget the nurse
came and she was we got to draw blood oh
look
you don't want to join all [ __ ] blood
she's like yes we do we have to drop
lego look i'm not the way i'm feeling
you say i pissed the [ __ ] bed i have
fear oozing out of me they're going to
be fine you're a big kid we'll do it
standing up and i kept saying i don't
want to give you blood in those days
they had like a little cart that they
pushed yeah
the nurses were changing the sheets i
remember this dumb nurse took me outside
into the hallway
and she goes you ready yeah she strapped
my arm
and she put the needle in there and guys
i swear to god i don't remember nothing
i remember waking up on top of her
really the needle in my arm blood all
over my [ __ ] arm i fainted and took
her down with me the cart tipped over oh
my god tremendous after that they had a
[ __ ]
take but i hate that this ball is made
oh my god wait i'm on with you
i [ __ ] hate walking through them me
too
i don't want to ever see anybody i don't
want to wind up there
oh even if something happens to me
please don't let it be there when i get
the surgeries on my knees i have one
surgery on my elbow and that was like
traumatic for me i can't spend the night
that's a [ __ ] nightmare that's a
[ __ ] nightmare with those ham and
turkeys lee likes those turkeys
lee would come home from see the sign
and go that food was delicious
i don't like that i told the guy not to
even knock me out he gave me like
twilight because you won't be you'll be
out but because your eyes were open the
entire time jesus yeah it was you it's
hilarious and you were [ __ ] we became
friends being this guy he goes and you
were telling me you were going to beat
me in basketball he goes i never saw
anybody so funny and then i woke up
crying after i i didn't i don't i don't
remember my eyes being open i said my
eyes were open because yeah wide open
and you talk through the entire
operation that's that's [ __ ] crazy
man
then afterwards i freaked out he gave me
norco and i almost jumped out the window
the pills yeah i went home i was
hallucinating i was running around the
house
i was running around my brother because
what's wrong with you you sound like
you're freaking i said yeah i'm going
insane i was taking that thing off the
surgery we were doing uh i was doing
chuck and larry then and it was i had a
little break and i had 12 something
right off my elbow i tore this thing
right off the bone i freaked out
unbelievable traumatic experience yeah
put some tony bennett on you listen yeah
put a little bennett on there a little
better
some [ __ ] we're here at the halfway mark
it's monday
talking to my main man nicky tricky
tricky nicki gene adams
here we have gene evans
oh yeah
i love this
it's beautiful
beautiful
wow that's music
that's this [ __ ] today
this is beautiful huh how you feeling
lisa what's going on with your dad's
coming you're excited he's coming in
august what'd you say for father's day
you said you sent him a [ __ ] i sent
him a crystal book he just started
liking to read so i bought a billy
crystal book a johnny carson book and
then actually a pretty cool thing that's
on or was on hbo it's billy crystal
talking about like the 700 sundays he
had but his father he liked that nick
liked that i enjoyed it i sent him that
too
like how old is your dad
63 yeah 63. he's in good health yeah
he's doing good he's down in florida
he's retired he's great he's having a
good time you're lucky man my dad passed
the 63 but i'm saying
you know stay stay close to them because
you only get one father i've started
freaking out i'm not freaking out but i
started thinking about it and then i got
this notification on my phone that said
i was almost out of voicemail space but
i'm just i'm just not deleting
voicemails from my parents anymore i
feel like i would like i'd like
the ones that your mom just called and
says call me back delete those who gives
a [ __ ]
she calls you with a good story on the
phone and tells you to send you a check
something like that
that'd be a good one to keep yeah
you know listen to that tony bennett i'm
starting to buy albums again
i'm going to these cd trader stores i'm
i'm into buying albums again because
there's just something about having an
album you know what i mean with the not
like the cds the tapes they don't
there's something special about the
whole event put the album on you know
the record playing i got the turntables
i'm i'm back into it man i'm back into
getting albums again it's that fast i
love it it just makes me i don't know
there's something special about that you
know it's like watching a black and
white movie it's just something
beautiful about that whole
that whole experience of buying albums
again you know louie premier bryan
sinatra angle bird humperdink all these
guys pumperdink we call him pumperdink
my dad said yeah puts on some pumperdink
you know
i don't know i like it i don't mean even
soundtracks i bought scarface i found
the scarface soundtrack it's a good
soundtrack actually really good you know
it's uh
when you talk about
albums you know people like lee doesn't
have a [ __ ] clue i'm not mad at them
i just
lee doesn't have a clue about
the album experience they came up with
to see the experience now today it's
even different and uh that's computer
yeah it's computer where there's no
experience it's just a download download
vinyl is coming like i just got into
vinyl did you get the turntable yeah i
have the turntable and i listened to the
first half of houses of holy today
what'd you think it was good i was i
just was doing some work in the it was
crazy yeah it was first two songs
because one the one of the songs
is kind of like
really melancholy
no no no no that one you don't have to
go oh
oh and then the other ways dancing days
are here again oh yeah and it goes into
no quarter in the ocean which is the
meat potatoes of the [ __ ] album right
there
wow but it's it's really coming back
uh it was a different and then
i didn't insult me when i say he didn't
know what the [ __ ] i don't know what i'm
talking about i'm happy that you do have
that because it's a different
you know there was nothing like
walking to the record store on a
saturday right okay you either had a
paper round right or you had your 13th
birthday whatever the [ __ ] you had cash
and you already know what the album cost
with tax exactly you knew it was seven
dollars and sixty two [ __ ] seconds
really right you know so true you knew
lee you [ __ ] knew it's right so cool
you knew it was like going to buy a pair
of converse you know they were ten
dollars
i'm gonna go get my new chuck 9.99 plus
tax that was a lot of money what's a lot
of [ __ ] money what day did records
come out is there like a day of the week
or day of the month nothing like that it
was like they just came out and you went
up there there was always the [ __ ]
jerk off in the neighborhood sam goodies
that got the first down and told you it
was good and you couldn't wait till
saturday to walk up there and get the
album but it was exciting it was
exciting you walked home 20 blocks with
this [ __ ] album
and you had to walk through a black
neighborhood so you got to hide the
armor you get jumped and they take your
[ __ ] album you know that
uh i have a friend eddie problem one
night i was doing comedy and he was just
talking to me about how when he loved
kiss he couldn't let the buddies in the
neighborhood know that he like kissed
cause they beat him up oh he had to
sneak an arm home and put it under his
bed he couldn't even he had to keep it
from his brother
you know that's now you just download
something keep it in your emails
whatever the [ __ ] you keep on your
itunes list whatever right but just to
have the album to go home put it on and
to read the album cover and the sleeve
it meant the world to you what hotel
they stayed on the road who their
managers were i want to thank my
daughter crystal you know they gave you
pictures they gave you lyrics
you know you paid but they gave you
this thing now you have yeah now you
give me a different experience i'm not
putting down the experience you're
giving me now
now i could go on twitter and talk to
dave grow
you know i could i could possibly do
something with a celebrity you know when
i was a kid you had a picture of elton
john on your wall right there was no way
of talking to him on twitter or facebook
or you know instagramming with that
[ __ ] or whatever
it was a different experience that you
cherish more it was more personal less
personal you brought it home that album
cover you know there is nobody that's my
age or younger that walks into an album
store today
and has to stop when they see album
covers that you forgot completely about
i know you just and they do something to
you they freeze you in time like you
guys are going to be frozen in time when
you hear the infected mushrooms 40 years
from now you know i remember dancing in
the office for joey that night all
[ __ ] up
but it's so weird how that i have always
loved that experience like i you know i
think of one arm that i sat there for
hours and looked at the doors american
dream with the poetry inside
and the [ __ ] pictures he wrote all
[ __ ] up but it didn't matter you read
the van halen i remember still getting a
poster in van halen three the worst down
woman and children first zeppelin the
lead cream the rolling
ralph had all these albums
is to look at them and go wow this is
something where'd you get this who's
this guy jimi hendrix orange cover
you know man just like he just blew you
away he was like you're right it just
it was just so special to look at it it
was it meant something i don't know
that's great that america's getting back
in
it's good it's happening no it's great
and i knew it would i knew it would i
knew it would i knew it would because it
just makes sense man it's too much drama
to play music you know for you i mean
when i was growing up
all the [ __ ]
guppies the yuppies or whatever they
were in 1980 oh no it's the reel-to-reel
man yeah everything was the [ __ ] real
to really
[ __ ] came and went like a bullet in
the night right everybody kept saying oh
my realtor real i can hear when the
singer pulls away from the mic when he's
stop
stop
is it remember what was the big
commercial we were kids is it live or is
it memorex right right memorex ran [ __ ]
back then that's right uh
you know and then it went to cassettes
and then i went to cds and yeah you know
i even like the eight tracks i think
that every year they just con people
look at it and now it's back to albums
if everybody would have just kept buying
albums and kept those needles on the
thing we're right back where the [ __ ] we
started from so i hope you dummies
learned the [ __ ] valuable lesson and
the [ __ ] 45s the 45s one song in this
[ __ ] one song and the other shitty one
right
on the flip side
uh and they'd sell how much of the 45 is
a dollar it would cheat a dollar yeah
because a dollar you know what i love
the labels you see all the stevie wonder
song the colors of the label i bought
this tom jones album it says parrot has
a green i love the labels or these the
color of them you gotta i'm telling you
very interesting lee you just watched an
episode of sopranos yes when they uh
sell the houses
yeah to the people what happened when
they were in the sauna
when they oh girl what did tony soprano
say to the black guy the shylites the
best
and he goes and the guy goes the [ __ ]
up thing was they were on such and such
label with tony dorsey
and he goes no they weren't
and he goes okay and they ended the
conversation there in those days you
knew what label
you're yeah he got even more intense he
said he said like
they only want idiots to think that or
something like really like rude right
well what happened was in those days was
the ma you know they were talking about
all that great music came out of new
jersey frankie valley right and it was
all paola
so what they would do is the mob would
make partners with a record company
they'd go to the record they go to the
radios they'd [ __ ] give the radio
money to play their music that's how you
make a hit
i can't make a hit unless i play your
[ __ ] music right so that's how the
hits were made that's how they played
your music so you could sell more of it
so all those mobsters if you watched
hesh the jew owned the record did you
see the pilot when the black guys wanted
to have a meeting with him yeah what
happened with that nothing ever came
from that because nah probably did but
the sopranos aren't gonna tell you it's
for the imagination it's like till this
day people sit around and wonder what
happened to the russian in the woods
oh that that never gets resolved no a
lot of things were left on
like that left
four i like that your cousin by the way
is really good i hate her but she's
really good she was very good in the
show yeah
that was a great show that was really
first for a couple of years but that was
joe was riveting i have to admit
it was really [ __ ] listen if it
wasn't for that show listen i love
michael jordan but if it wasn't for
julius erving there'd be no michael
jordan that's right
that's right you know i love uh
breaking bad and i love sons of anarchy
but they all came from the sopranos that
that character that guy that could you
know ricky ricardo went home to his wife
every night the guy from the walton said
good night john boyd yeah this guy went
out to a strip club that he was a
partner in he [ __ ] other women and you
still watched every week to watch sony
soprano you still like them you still
like them that was the show that's the
show
women like your wife will look at him
and go i'm not going to watch this this
guy cheats on his wife but you liked him
you fell in love with the character you
fell in love with him so much that
you're like who gives a [ __ ] if he
cheats on his wife
constantly that's a [ __ ] gift
that's a real show that makes you forget
about your what you stand for exactly
it wasn't like they analyzed it and said
oh this guy is not narcissistic he's not
likable other people are going to watch
it and i'm like the guy was [ __ ] that
you know unlikable guy in the world but
people liked them they liked them so if
you that's why the networks wouldn't do
a show like that the networks would not
never do a show like that because
they're always about you got to be
likable you got to be you know you can't
be unlikely about that [ __ ] yeah but
that's what was great about that's what
the show was about that you didn't give
up he didn't give a [ __ ]
it's a great [ __ ] [ __ ] always root
for bad guys they root for villains they
they love they love the bad boys and
some he was a bad boy that had you know
he was deep he wasn't like a one-note
guy so you you would justify some of his
you know flaws you were more fascinating
by a guy who's not perfect
much more fascinating that's why ralph
crammed it and he said tell his wife
i'll punch you right in the face go to
the moon you never see comedies like
that you know you couldn't get away with
that [ __ ] today you know i mean but he
was great you loved him at the end of
the day he was a lovable loser that's
with tony soprano they loved that
character he was a great guy and a great
actor that did it and the guy was
[ __ ] great the writing was great but
james was tremendous i mean you know you
see the world warrior yeah which one mad
max no no one yeah
yeah the guy is good i like tom hardy oh
he's a good actor i like that he is a
very good he's good he's good yeah he's
deep he's good in that the one with gay
lefini
it was a bad movie it was a bad movie
but he was good i saw him in the the
warrior movie i liked him a lot the more
with the brothers he was like a wrestler
that was a good movie that's a good
movie and there's a movie called bronson
bronson yeah that's good in that too i
turned it on yeah i had to turn it off
it was disturbing it's a little weird
but i like do you see that lee no i
haven't seen it
is it about charles bronson no no not
about this character named charles brown
prison his whole life he's a notorious
[ __ ] criminal villain of death and
all this [ __ ]
i can't believe gandolfini's gone that's
[ __ ] weird i mean when he died it was
just like
shocking my brother went to
the funeral he said never saw so many
people crying because it was really
really sad he was at my mother's week
and everything he didn't move with john
and um
he just it was something about the guy
that he was you could tell people loved
him he was a giving guy
yeah you know he gave to the uh the cast
he fought for people he fought but he
wasn't like a douchebag you know a lot
of guys are not in a position they don't
care about the rest of the cast they
don't care about this guy he had a he
had a big heart but he was i think he
was a dark guy you know deep down he had
a lot of demons
his demons did him in you know
unfortunate but that's what made him so
great man
i saw him i remember hugging him in my
mother's wake and i could tell i said
this guy's a
that's why that's why i was driven to
him as an actor you know he was a great
character actor then all of a sudden he
got this part and i was like wow i knew
he was good but i know he was that good
he was like really [ __ ] good he was
really good he he had some
weight you know i mean i'm not talking
about his weight i mean he just had some
he had some real chops and and he was
good with women
you know for for a guy that wasn't
beautiful he was a sexy [ __ ] guy with
women like you know his overweight he
was fat but you know he loved you love
seeing them in bed [ __ ] women and you
know making love and [ __ ] like that and
be alan bella shiora he had all these
wild affairs the one chick with the one
leg i mean
oh he [ __ ] everybody
now he's [ __ ] the cuban girl yeah oh
man yeah he just hooked up with the
horse lady the horse lady but he was
good with women there were some guys
that you go they're good with women like
you know like de niro he's never been
good with women he looks awkward with
women but gandolfini was actually like
he was a sexy [ __ ] with women
you know he just had that sex appeal can
you believe the scene between tony and
his cousin asking her about ralph's sex
life there's a brother and a sister he
gave her three grand he goes he goes
three grand he goes how did you come up
with that figure and he goes i've picked
one i thought he would say yes to you
guessed right he was so mean to the oh
my god he was so mean at times you know
he was mean but she was crazy she's just
so crazy
when he goes to put her on the bus and
she goes tell me what'd you do with them
we buried them up on the hill
overlooking flowers
he [ __ ] sold it oh yeah he [ __ ]
sold it's really good to see somebody
sell it yeah i love to see actors sell
it i was meeting with these writers last
week and we were talking about flashback
scenes and movies
and we're talking about you know what if
the person if you commit to the
flashback
it's a tremendous [ __ ] flashback you
know yeah it's it's tough to do
something that's always easy to no
flashbacks off it's not always no no
some of it was good and some of it
wasn't that they didn't always nail it
you know but um you're right those
flashbacks are
you know sometimes when they're done
well it could be brilliant
but it's not easy
and not easy to do
you know
i mean i can golf all the two it's great
you know when they do the flashback
scenes it's just beautiful
the way you know you just forget
you know you go from once one time to
another time and you're completely with
that time you know the way they did that
it was just beautiful
in all the godfather movies i think my
favorite scene is the end of two
when they go back to the
the kitchen and they're talking about uh
you know hurry up we brought a cake for
pop yeah that is to me it's a great
scene that to me is one of the greatest
scenes yeah in movie history and they're
like it's a great scene because i enjoy
the congratulations don't [ __ ]
encourage him yeah stupid stupid stupid
james kind of so good oh my god
but you know if you went to an italian
house or an irish house it was like that
or a house with
[ __ ] passion right that's the house
the passion that the mother finally
gotta come and go stop stop stop stop
with the [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] she's
cursing and she's telling you to stop
cursing just like when they're eating in
the first one and and paulo tries to say
you you know because i can help you out
you know we don't discuss business at
the table you know those [ __ ] are up
there right now
we don't discuss people we don't discuss
business
like you're right you know they don't
that that takes you back you know that
other scene is great when they're all
sitting around i don't know where's luca
i don't know he's shacked up or
something oh my god that's a great scene
what's up yeah yeah that's a great
scenario
just answer the phone they're not
expecting me right
awesome all right
oh my god they all start giggling oh my
god dude starts laughing coming lenses
that guy was great richard castellano he
lived in north bergen he was did he yeah
great actually
my buddy called in the assemblyman
that's where the funeral had so they had
the funeral yeah
i never saw him he lived in the at the
the grinder now everybody who does coke
lives at this building it's circular so
they call it the grinder i just saw
pacino on a uh was charlie rose the
other night he's great he's a great
interview he really is you know he's
very articulate pacino i said some great
stuff fascinating stuff he's talking
about early in his career he's saying
like you know i didn't even think i was
so good and my body goes i didn't know
if i you know i was going to make it
this big and i had a friend that was
saying when good things would happen to
me it should be happening to me not you
and pacino goes yeah i know this was his
friend telling him why isn't it
happening to me why is it happening to
you and al said you know he goes this my
friend of mine wanted it he goes he
wanted it but he goes i guess
i had to have it
he goes you know like my friend wanted
it but i had to have it
the way he said that like you know like
as much as people are humble and say i'm
lucky man but when somebody wants
something that's one thing it's like a
woman yeah i want her but i have to have
her i have to suck her titties
i have to kiss her
i have to go out i mean i told my
brother one time i was doing more better
blue does it is chick cinder she's
gorgeous mulatto
i'm going to kiss her on the mount
because
you're insane i said no i'm going to
kiss her
watch i'm going to go over there i'm
going to kiss i ran on the lips because
i had to kiss her i had to taste her
lips
i couldn't i didn't want it i had to
have it
and sometimes you just have to have it
and that's a very powerful statement
and i get lost a little bit thinking
about it but you know it's true
you know what it's uh
lee and i were having a conversation or
wanting something lee like that i don't
know yeah
i'm just worried if there's any assault
charges pending that you just admitted
to or oh did it why what's wrong
no but like just having to kiss a girl
yeah
he was moved by the blues it was 20
years ago
on the [ __ ] computer [ __ ] he's going
to jesus christ you're worse than law
enforcement i'm worried about him he's
like a pending dane my neck he's on my
neck he said my [ __ ] neck yeah i
tried them seven grand
unbelievable yeah you really thought
what are you laughing about but lee and
i were having a conversation that you
could tell i love when he looks at the
weight he goes what the [ __ ] do you want
okay well lee and i were talking about
like
how i felt in 1995 coming back from
doing comedy
and how long are you doing comedy 24
years and sitting there going
what's today's day oh my god it was last
uh
it was thursday 24 years ago 22nd yeah
24 years
and i remember doing tommy like five
years and and crying at night
crying neck crying myself to sleep going
i don't know how to improve in the time
i didn't think in my mind right i didn't
think i had a big window
i had to get good fast and i know the
only way to do that was to get on stage
you have to get on stage every [ __ ]
night
and write every day so i got on stage
every opportunity
but boulder denver had a limited amount
of stage time you know i could sneak up
on [ __ ] uh karaoke night here i would
sneak into an open poetry night one
night until they caught on they threw me
the [ __ ] out of there
so when uh
i don't know when i got cut loose from
denver i decided to leave and moved to
seattle
that pain really
it was it was the pain of wanting it man
wanting to get good wanting to work you
know right i didn't want to be in movies
on tv i just want to be a good stand-up
so i had something to do with my life i
just wanted i wanted to do something
with my life you know
even if i didn't headline i didn't care
even if i got 600 a week and lived in my
car i didn't care nick at that time at
the age of 32 i just wanted to get good
at calmly you know it was a certain ban
and unless you have that pain you really
can't describe it to people that's true
the the pain of wanting and then
deciding that you're going to commit to
this this is what you're [ __ ] doing
right like just that [ __ ] pain you
know like you know what enough is enough
that's what i'm doing
it takes a certain uh
you know last week i yelled to lee and i
didn't apologize to him because
he got me mad because he watched nine
episodes of his show
you know
and my argument was it was a friday
there's money to be made on a friday you
cannot sit in front of a tv for nine and
he knows i love him i mean he didn't get
mad at me
he knows i'm breaking his balls because
it's a discipline
it's a discipline in your mind that you
have to do something every day
you know and i know you're with your
girlfriend or whatever you have to take
her home and say i'll pick you up in
five hours even if you're just gonna go
home and walk off on the couch it's a
discipline you develop a discipline to
doing something that's right and that's
very important you know we talk about
people committing to stuff today i went
to jiu jitsu when i was leaving the guy
followed me out to the car and he goes i
gotta tell you something man
i didn't think we'd be having this
conversation two years later
because i thought you were gonna walk
out of here for the second week because
every time you come in here i'm so proud
of you
and that's how i was telling lee started
going to jiu jitsu on tuesday nights and
i go lee just go once a week
every time you go you're beating the
odds of people because in this country
the way we are today nobody commits to
nothing nick you see it you see it they
come to you with a [ __ ] tv show uh we
did this and we're going to pitch and
then also they just disappear and also
you look them up on facebook and they're
back in connecticut working at the
[ __ ] highlight thing and you're like
you were just here telling me you were
going to be the next [ __ ] uh what was
[ __ ] uh the tequila guy from cuba
whatever his name is i have no idea the
commitment level in this country has
gone people do not want to put in you
know and listen i'm not gonna [ __ ]
lie to you and tell you i was any
different when i was 19 i walked into
the electricians union and they were
like yeah the first year you make 15
bucks an hour 12 whatever 1192 was this
and then the third year and after five
years when you're 21 you look at five
years ago go [ __ ] yourself you know even
the service you're like you know what
i'm gonna get shot after a year so it
doesn't really matter i'm not doing four
years in the service nobody joins the
service since they're gonna last night
for four years but if you commit to
something the time passes so [ __ ]
fast
we have forgotten you know and that's
all i meant the other day league i
didn't mean it about that no i i totally
understand that we're insulting you not
i didn't take it like that i wasn't mad
at you i was just saying that but but
then after today look at mark maron
you've told me like he he took
a career that wasn't going where he
wanted to go what was that we discussed
as him and i last week oh my god
we have a friend mark man great guy i've
known him in comedy since 97. i had a
little tiff with him in 98 over cocaine
and we discussed on his podcast and we
never talked for a while i'd see him i'd
say hello he was great and almost famous
i went up to him and shook his hand and
said you were great you should really
pursue acting
you know and he was with three arts he
was one of david becky's first clients
at three yards david becky's one of the
most powerful guys in hollywood he's got
louis ck and tracy morgan and [ __ ]
he's got all the comedians in that level
they go to three yards kevin hart's with
three yards those are the people that's
the place huh that's the place so
you know he was down and out things
weren't going his way which happens in
the city you know you have peace and
valleys and sometimes you just cannot
wait for your [ __ ] agent sometimes
you cannot wait for your friend who's a
friend of clint eastwood who said he's
gonna put you in jersey boys sometimes
you just say [ __ ] it
he called the most powerful one of the
most powerful guys in the commie
division
at three yards and said yeah
i'm working on a podcast
and the guy looked on and said what are
you talking about
that's [ __ ] shitty radio
and they giggle
the guy took an insult fired him
and today that guy's mark maron who had
a show put on because of his podcast but
friday obama went on it
on marc maron's podcast podcast yeah and
his [ __ ] garage
in what town like pasadena
yeah obama went with the helicopter the
whole thing the sun valley wow went in
his garage
it was on world news tonight him saying
the word [ __ ] on the podcast talking
about racism he actually had a real
conversation a real conversation with
obama i'm so happy okay do you
understand me what the magnitude of this
is this is a guy that they looked at and
said the top comedy this is what i said
to you last week when we're having that
discussion about starting up and i said
to you don't these guys these agents
these tv people they have no idea it's
like they don't have no idea about the
internet right
there yeah they have no idea they're
arguing still well we're gonna rate they
don't even know
they don't know they don't know
youtube's getting paid nobody else you
put a video up on youtube they played a
million times you got 18 you know
my point is they don't know this is this
is our genre this is why they're
confused with this they don't know we
make our own prices
we set our own we make remember when i
kind of when when tina turner put the
movie out the real what's love got to do
with it i turned and got pissed off in
real life and he hired a publicist and
he went on an all-out parade and in new
york city he said we're going to make
our own movies we're making our own
movies we're writing our own books and
that's when the guy said to him so is it
true
you used to beat up on tina turner
because i never beat up one i just
punched in the face a couple times
he said this at a press conference oh my
god i just punched in the face a couple
of times [ __ ]
but that's the problem that they don't
really know the magnitude of this thing
this is
you know this is nine to five this is
people who go to work and go this is in
the supermarket late night
there's no howard stern late night what
do you do if you stock shelves late
night what do you listen to you can only
listen to alice and change so much
before you want to listen to these
different people different perspectives
because they have everything it's not
just comedians it's actors it's
wrestlers it's doctors it's people who
do taxes i saw a [ __ ] podcast for
taxes last year yeah
you know this is amazing this is a
[ __ ] a tremendous [ __ ] forum so
that is like groundbreaking that obama
went on this guy's podcast and i'm so
happy for him i gotta tell you i'm so
[ __ ] happy
listen man you know sometimes it's great
when somebody has a dream and somebody
tells them to go [ __ ] himself yeah
sometimes when you believe in your dream
that much that's when things happen
that's true that's when things happen
when you believe you've got to believe
me when your mother says to you you're a
loser go back to your father work with
him look he's worked at the plant for 40
years and you're like [ __ ] you ma
i'm out of here i'm going to the village
i'm painting my face black and i'm
singing [ __ ] that 25 songs there's a
market for that [ __ ] you
you never know until you try right this
guy left three yards
an agency that eventually they would
have done something they would have put
him on the louis show as a sidekick
something they cast that whole [ __ ]
show with retta on it that whole shows
is them town and country i'm see i'm
sorry that's his whole show they
packaged that whole show three yards he
looked around this thing and said you're
the hindu you're on it you're on it
you're on look at all the people in that
show yeah and parks and rec they're all
three arts people that's their show
that's what they do
you know mark maher did something really
cool and i've never met him but no i
like him now at the end of the podcast
he like he listed off like everybody who
helped him like the like the artist like
the guy with guys for the website he's
like producer but then he also he left a
lot of money on the table if you like i
don't know if you've listened to it he
only had one sponsor and i'm not even
sure if they were paying him he said
like thank you to squarespace so he he
left like
that podcast has probably been
downloaded over a million times already
really it has the one today with obama
they broke the bank today so how did
they get obama he has a big i mean no
the article i read said that someone of
his staffers was a fan
oh really obama was a fan no one on this
one of obama's staffers was a fan of
mark myrons oh i see him brought it to
his attention yeah wow this is big for
the pot this is it this is it now
somebody else might have a beef it might
go on corollas or you know
and here's what i was saying it's a
different form you cannot put a price on
this you could they don't know how to
this is an easy form this is just three
gentlemen talking we just had a great
conversation about food sports music you
know everything women you know whatever
the [ __ ] you want this is a beautiful
thing let me give some shout outs and
i'll get you out of here beautiful
nice and easy no [ __ ] drama how you
feeling [ __ ]
two stars is pretty much my limit ram i
love you over there in dublin thank you
for the kind words today corey leighton
corey butts
wolf g you know i love you the ufc the
ufc gym in san antonio sent us a few
t-shirts and some other things did you
have see jimmy yeah ufc gym in san
antonio eric white who's strength
smoking smoking lady j you smoking dirty
[ __ ] i'll see you this week joshua
arambula
and jeffrey stunk i think that jeremy
stork i think that's your [ __ ] name i
can't think of that right and then some
guy sent me a nice the cd
and they sent me they smoke a number and
play a number you're all legends diaz
and lily the guy's name is malt and he's
got his whole band here we got your cds
in the car
you have the polo right there sent me i
don't know the name of the [ __ ] band
they didn't put it on there
but what are you gonna do you know what
i'm saying you got different strokes
with different folks
what's going on my buddy so
what's your ideal [ __ ] day of food
give me like if
if you woke up in new york city at seven
in the morning you drank a little coffee
in your hotel room to go to a diner
where for what breakfast what give me
the breakfast nice thing i got scrambled
eggs so i get two eggs over easy
a little bacon home fries no turkey
bacon right no more time
turkey bacon [ __ ] that cup of black
coffee and a diner good black coffee
that's the best coffee you know what i
mean
i love grapefruit i like a little
grapefruit
you know a little sweet toast yeah yeah
wheat toast i even like white toast
wonder bread toasted
yeah brushed on that one sure what are
you taking notes for are you reporting
i'm writing down what i want to say
all right this is [ __ ] good some
brownies
you know what else what do you got for
lunch lunch
i get a nice uh
a nice uh
a nice meatball here
nice meatball here a little mozzarella
on the side the bread toast is a little
more toast the much burns on the edge
burns yeah the bread is crispy right
maybe then it's like for a nice slice of
pizza on the side outside while you're
waiting yeah while you're waiting for
them if i'm hungry enough maybe get a
little half of a calzone a good calzone
oh [ __ ] yeah that would be really nice
right
top it off at night with a nice [ __ ]
porterhouse steak how many ounces how
much meat can you eat i don't like them
too big you don't know you don't like
them too dude i don't like them 12
ounces good enough four ounces is
perfect what are you doing inside little
baked potato baked potato inside of
pasta you would do the side of spaghetti
pasta marinara that's it yeah you could
do a little pasta
[ __ ] yeah how about a little baked clams
big clams white clams casino yeah not
casino just bake cleanse clams nice
little nice loaf of bread with some
water for bread yeah stop what do you
get for dessert what kind of desserts in
your world dessert in my world little
espresso
and then i get a nice little spamoni you
know nice little nice little spamoni i
like a good cookie too you know i'm like
a big dessert unless it's really really
good pastry you know a good piece of pie
let's see what lunatic's gonna [ __ ]
say go ahead what [ __ ] menu are you
doing now you go first i'm still well no
i'm not i'm thinking what's for
breakfast go ahead okay
i like uh like egg bacon and cheese
sandwiches but i like them when you put
hash browns inside that's what i want
that's what i'm dealing with here what's
wrong with that disgusting now you know
when i make scrambled eggs i got a trick
and everybody goes crazy over them you
know what i do what do you do
burn the butter with oil olive oil put
butter then i put olive oil right butter
than olive oil then i let it smoke
it has to smoke up like the fire alarms
go off the alarms go off smoking so
scramble the eggs then throw the eggs in
turn them [ __ ] quick
because then they get a dark color the
eggs are dark and the taste no these
don't taste like scrambled eggs because
they burn the butter with the butter and
the olive oil and then i throw it in a
high flame but i flick it fast and it's
dark you never taste the scrambled egg
it tastes close to the diner type of
eggs but everybody goes can you make the
scrambled eggs like oh yeah cause they
don't taste like you put ketchup on your
scrambled eggs if you want afterwards
with some white i like pepper
a lot of pepper scrambled eggs with some
ketchup on that [ __ ] yeah i'll
tell you what's good too it's a good
nice slice thin sliced french toast
you know nice or even a more of a
pancake person but it's going to be thin
pancakes
is it not to make a nose thin i don't
like a big fat thick big fat i'm like i
don't want that i want no part of that
thick pancake it needs a thin
everything's got to be thin to me even
french toast should be i don't like it
too thick
i like it thin
yeah but i also like the the syrup to
the old-fashioned syrup i like that old
uh that's your mimer auntie my more
or the other one what is another one
this is work oh something like that i
forget no the maple the one i know which
one you're talking about you know what
i'm talking about
that [ __ ] you get in the bronx and [ __ ]
yeah at the [ __ ] boys club hey a good
salted bagel is good too you know give
me a nice salted bag with a little cream
cheese and a slice of tomato salt and
pepper whoo that's nice
a salted good salted bacon yeah you go
to western bagel yeah what's for bro to
breakfast at the least i had i said but
you know what actually isn't bad the
whole wheat uh pancakes at denny's
they're only like 150 each and then i
had sugar free syrup which i didn't
think was bad but i probably just
haven't had
sir appropriately you know what movie
makes me hungry
and it's a good movie that [ __ ] chef
movie yeah that's a good one i like that
movie favreau did a good job about it so
it wasn't a fantastic for lunch you're
not a fan i was i did 16 scenes i got
nowhere
in the eight scenes nine seeds nothing
happened i had to try i had to move on
with my
it it went from the same scenes it's
true but i like the movie hit me with
your day what's for lunch lunch is uh
okay i was i really thought i heard
about this i'm going with chinese food
generals chicken
egg roll and dumplings from where what
are you going to make frog no well i'm
just saying ideal
i don't know where i get them
yeah sure
and what's for dinner
uh sushi i was gonna get a steak but i
figured like sushi and like like
uh teriyaki
with beef teriyaki you don't like sushi
you like sushi i love sushi you get beef
terry what are you talking about like a
good eggplant parmesan i don't like
eggplant no no i like the cheese i take
the cheese off yeah the cheese well you
can't digest the cheese no i love cheese
i don't like eggplant you had my
favorite the other night the chicken
parm oh yeah from dantana's the chicken
pomegranates
oh [ __ ]
chicken pawing me like [ __ ] yeah that's
good i like chicken palm uh sandwich
from jersey yeah and shrimp jersey
that's good i love all that chicken
bread all the shrimp on with the [ __ ]
bread
you gotta see what i do with the olive
oil i put a little olive oil with a good
piece of bread right then i put grated
cheese salt and pepper
oh man what a mixture that is mix that
up grated cheese salt and pepper and a
good olive oil like a sicilian olive and
then dip that sucker but you got to mix
it up with the grated it has a flavor
salt and pepper
french bread you toast the bread or tell
me nah just italian breadcrumbs
i gotta get go get fresh bread i go to a
few places
yeah i know good bread i know you know
you got to get it fresh you can't let it
sit you know there's this bread of
domingos that they have it's very good
it's called um you know that bread i'm
talking about the one they use for their
sandwiches they use it yeah yeah but
it's very good bread and it's great for
dipping you know
where they really are the john's in the
valley right by me on magnolia and
laurel canyon
like it's the worst supermarket but they
always have fresh bread like the bins
are steaming and the people come from
like west hollywood to get it really
it's really it's crazy
it's really good bread
you're a good man lisa
i'm always on the lookout for food you
said you said i forgot i missed the
dunkin donuts so i had it it just opened
and encino
yeah but you can't wait in the morning
is there still a line yeah [ __ ] that
yeah
i go to dunkin donuts in new york new
jersey i don't really listen on the way
home stopping magnolia
and river
and cold
yum yum donuts
mexicans oh
get the glaze get the glaze going and
then get it done is it open now 24.
always open how where do i go
show them how you go lee how do you go
where is it
make a u-turn right here stay on
lancashire
and uh and go they got a good jelly
donut oh they gotta go to everything
jelly donut though i don't like
chocolate i like a good chocolate
chocolate dipped in coconut they got the
glass place in this you know k's donuts
they're good
they're good are they open right now no
i gotta go to yum yum yum yum oh i think
i know what you're talking about i love
hollywood high school it's not too far
from here right no two minutes that's
what i'm saying stop over there on the
way home
they'll [ __ ] love you forever
got her a cuban sandwich [ __ ]
will go crazy chocolate cream donut or
something
oh man
i'm looking i'm going home in september
i'm really looking forward to i'm gonna
get some chinese food from my spot
i'm gonna get some calamar from my spot
rooties i've been eating this since i'm
16.
and i'm going to go to my other spot say
calamazi oh my
that red hook
um the places sheepshead bay have been
randazzo's 22 [ __ ] years ago
years ago right the sweet sauce oh
that's when you have calamari he went
through these ribs yeah he got mad at me
because okay we had just started working
together what'd you get at rudy's oh you
you hated me
i wanted to order well i didn't want to
order but i was still too nervous to
order something expensive so i got like
i tried to order cheese ravioli and
you're like you do not get cheese
ravioli i was going to strangle it so
good i think i got like shrimp scampi or
something which is good but i have still
two i was like i don't think i should
order anything expensive yeah that's
what we were there for to eat like
savages you know i'm gonna take it to
new york and make you eat like [ __ ]
cantina food take it in new york what do
you mean you're tying food out here joe
what do you like i got a measuring house
that's it yeah you like that
it's not that i like it it's easy the
family likes it right the bread is
horrifically [ __ ] bad
the spaghetti and meatballs and mensa
last week i went for the [ __ ] the
steak pizza hole they gave me a steak
with no sauce on them oh my god yeah no
they didn't yes they did yes they did i
almost said something but i they don't
know the guy doesn't know
listen to this they got shrimp fried
diablo
with a side of pasta yeah i go why don't
you put it on the pot we don't do that
here it's shrimp fried diablo with a
side of spaghetti and meat sauce the
whole point is the pasta and the whole
point is the pasta they give you four
shrimp in it they just don't know they
don't get and they try to have escarole
and beans you have a cup you will drink
80 gallons of water from how much salt
that mexican butter oh my god there's so
much salt they usually you make that
right the escarole with the beans oh
it's delicious it's the happy hour it's
the happy hour fantastic at the bar it's
called them beans with a nice cup of
wine at the bottom escarole is great you
gotta cook that right and get the right
beans it's a fantastic day you've had
the pacifist rule from whole foods
thirteen dollars for a cup it's [ __ ]
horrific it's like chili it tastes like
[ __ ] chili i make my own
next time you make it invite me please
because i'm a big boss
that [ __ ] kills aids if you make it
right this [ __ ] kills the head it'll
kill it you freeze it and you take it
out in november after the first
snowstorm you could suck a crackhole's
dick
you could suck caitlyn jenner's dick
what's in it
yeah
that's
whatever they put in it what's that
grass
i don't know what do you put in your
pasta
i just i you know
i steam it and [ __ ] beans what else what
up garlic sauce what else what kind of
grass you put he really likes plastic
though yeah what kind of grass you put
in there you gotta put something in
there put no [ __ ] grass i use this
gut oil okay where do you get the
scuttle from i get it from the
supermarket okay then nice and that's
gotta wait anything you gotta do once it
gets from somebody's backyard
i don't [ __ ] know you gotta ask i
think he imports it did he go to
[ __ ] there's no remember when
[ __ ] in my blue heaven when steve
martin went to the supermarket what was
he looking for
was it broccoli robinson it's something
buckler or something that's better [ __ ]
i like it but it's i don't like that
[ __ ] sometimes it's just too much better
i prefer to scuttle i don't like
broccoli
i know something about
broccoli and cheese looks good though
broccoli with a little cheese on top
when you're stoned you'll give it a
second look until you taste it even
though broccoli rob when it's you know
when you make it right and it's not too
bitter with cheap melted cheese on it
yeah this guy's always trying to change
and he's chatting around everything
everybody's cheddar no they don't no
cheddar is what you eat when you [ __ ]
go to catch up i made some nice linguini
with clam sauce today yeah see what i'm
saying
cheese in your house there's no cheddar
cheese in your [ __ ] house yeah
america i'm making grilled cheese
yeah but you use americans mac and
cheese slice den that's what you do yeah
no more cheddar with you chad is for
[ __ ] you know someone has to say for
vermont vermont who gives a [ __ ] about
she have a [ __ ] food show there's a
dude
people don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] that's
what i'm saying they don't know how to
eat they've forgotten this country has
forgotten how to eat they all eat cheap
i like to do a sunday show or every
sunday you know we we do a dinner but we
have this idea about sunday denver yeah
everybody lamb chops lamb lamb's really
excited you could do a different family
dinner every sunday you do it right
how does that work past like
15 episodes though
it's the people it's a different couple
every dinner then we go to a couple
different other jews house all right ah
same place come over my house the other
side of israel and the other people from
the other sides of israel and they
[ __ ] he cooked something different
what's with the question
let's go for the sponsors get the [ __ ]
out of it
where's the air i'm dying
i'm sick and tired of telling you
[ __ ] on it for all your uh
supplement needs from new mood to stream
shroom tech
sport
and immune
also that bread and butter the hemp
protein the chocolate is [ __ ]
delicious off of vanilla ice ie
or give the uh what else a try oh
[ __ ] alpha brain that's what i'm
talking about here why [ __ ] around all
right alpha brain is one of the best
nootropics on the market complete with
alpha gpcs and ac-1 don't ask me what
that is i have no [ __ ] idea i know it
works i know that your memory is sharp i
know that you become sharp why take it
from me it's a money-back guarantee they
don't even want the product back go to
honda.com and press in church oh [ __ ]
c-h-u-r-c-h
and get 10 off your first order they
also have the stay on it program that
you could just [ __ ] get it delivered
to your door on them on the first of the
month how easy is that
number two
nailed it life aka los gumis or manos
you want to see the devil whether it's a
vapor pen or with those gummies romano's
the gummy bear the new chocolate bars it
don't [ __ ] matter they might be here
wednesday night so we're gonna do a
podcast wednesday afternoon and leo
probably sleep the [ __ ] night because
they got 800 milligram chocolate bars or
some [ __ ] they said they're making a
special one for me
but don't [ __ ] take it from me go to
nailed it live.com the vapor pen the
best on the market you get 20 off it's
usually 50 bucks when they give it to
you for 40 bucks go to uh nailed it
life.com and press in
joey diaz and get [ __ ] 20 off
your first order you got a problem you
call david he'll replace a [ __ ]
whatever you got all right number three
my main [ __ ] hit e6
the proof is in the vapor 1200
guaranteed hits when you go to 7-eleven
and buy one of those isis cigarettes how
many hits you got in there maybe 82.
[ __ ] you with hit e6 you got 1200 and
they come in the cigar they come in
different flavors and you get them in 24
eight and 16
milligrams who's better than [ __ ] you
so go to
86.com and press in joey's church and
get five for fifty five for fifty or
twenty percent off i don't know what
deal they're running but you ain't gonna
know till you get there right get down
there tell them uncle joey it'll be a
surprise that's right i want to give
another shout out to on it nailed it
life and headysigs.com for being
tremendous sponsors and believing in us
and i want to thank you guys for [ __ ]
listening and watching and giving us the
love we deserve what's up [ __ ] all
right buddy thanks for having me i'm
happy you came you make me [ __ ] laugh
like nobody else though cause you do it
on the match
everybody else tries to be funny you do
it on the [ __ ] match lee put the hair
on
i'm sweating [ __ ] bullets back here i
think you might be having an issue then
maybe i do i love you [ __ ] thank
you